[Musique]
tous
je n'ai jamais été facile d'être juif
ici mais ce qui nous pousse et c'est
l'idée que ça devient de plus en plus
facile et qu'un jour ça deviendra
normale et banale
journaliste bien connu en pologne comme
standing et verte connaît bien la
complexité de la vie juive dans son pays
après le low cost
aujourd'hui un des piliers de la
communauté qui avant la guerre comptez 3
millions et demi de personnes
il déplore la récente donc l
antisémitisme à des gens me demandent si
je pense que ce temps de partir la
quantité des insultes et des menaces
adressée à notre communauté à augmenter
de plusieurs fois on a dû augmenter la
sécurité
pour lui il n'ya pas de doute la
nouvelle loi polonaise était en février
qui interdit de lier publiquement l'état
polonais ou la nation polonaise aux
crimes commis par l'allemagne nazie a
provoqué une vague d'hostilité envers
les juifs comme on n'en a pas vu depuis
des décennies le grand rabbin de pologne
un américain qui lie à varsovie depuis
près de 30 ans est lui aussi très
préoccupé on entend des choses qu'on n'a
pas entendu depuis 1989 au maine 1968
déplore-t-il qu'ils s'en aillent en
palestine les juifs ne sont pas des
humains ce sont des animaux ils
voulaient eux mêmes à l'est dans les
ghettos
il synthétise en pologne où vous voyez
yann jarring historien et sénateurs du
parti droit et justice
au pouvoir depuis trois ans est un
ardent défenseur de la nouvelle loi
selon lui la pologne qui a retrouvé son
indépendance en se libérant du joug
communiste il y a à peine un quart de
siècle commence tout juste à raconter la
véritable histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale nous avons réussi
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale si le tout est dit est parlé
par les communautés juif aux états unis
canada aussi un an israël où nous avons
reçu l'information que voilà nous sommes
aussi quand les nazis
nous sommes responsables de caracas il
faut que faire quelque chose pour
terminer c'était
france cette situation si je dis les
juifs veulent avoir le monopole de la
victime qui se dévider de la majorité ou
pendant la seconde guerre beaucoup de
juifs sont morts mais aussi beaucoup de
polonais non il n'y a pas eu qu'à nos
locaux il ya eu aussi impôts locaux au
niveau local ce numéro choc de l'édition
polonaise du magazine newsweek annonce
un nouveau livre paru il ya quelques
jours la direction d'un historien canado
polonais professeur à l'université
d'ottawa 1700 pages où on peut lire que
sur trois juifs rescapés des rafles
nazies 2 août était achevée par des
concitoyens peu le nez c'est vraiment
dans le cadre de la recherche portant
sur la deuxième guerre mondiale que les
polonais se retrouvent comme les victhom
la victime innocente de la période la
plus brutale en histoire humaine voilà
tout à coup on arrive avec cette vision
du passé bien différente on dit
notamment que les victimes peuvent être
à la fois violent contre encore les gens
qui sont dans une situation encore pire
je connais la vérité de ma famille
je ne veux pas recevoir l'information
que moi mes parents ils n'ont pas gardé
les juifs ils ont tué les juifs se
parlait mais les résultats des
recherches historiques sont impitoyables
si la famille du sénateur a caché un
couple de juifs
le mythe de la pologne qui massivement
et héroïquement tenter de sauver sa plus
grande minorité nationale délais des
bourreaux nazis ne résiste pas aux faits
il faut savoir que l'esprit de
gouvernement polonais de parti au
pouvoir ne va pas changer d'un jour à
l'autre ce sont les nationalistes
convaincu pour qui la vision le
rassemblement des mythes nationaux et
qui les inspire c'est une question de
religion plie de croyance
dans le musée pauline ouvert il ya cinq
ans à varsovie on retrace mille ans de
présence juive en pologne avec l'accent
sur une cohabitation plutôt harmonieuse
sans éviter les pages noires la seconde
guerre mondiale qui a vu disparaître 90%
de la communauté
je dansais naturaliste ou encore
l'histoire plus récente il ya cinquante
ans plus de 13000 juifs ont été chassé
du pays par les autorités communistes
dans l'indifférence générale
l'exposition qui est consacrée à fâcher
les autorités quand je pense aux
rouilles et mes chiens ou pas d'eau
bénite
elle nous reproche de comparer la
campagne antisémite de 1968 rapport à
celle qui a lieu aujourd'hui dit la
responsable de l'exposition
j'aurais aimé mieux ne pas avoir à le
faire mais ce discours n 2 a été
ressuscité et il faudra parler
ouvertement et le condamner
[Musique]
toutes les institutions qui traite de
l'histoire de la pologne sont
aujourd'hui sous la loupe des autorités
de leur version de la fierté nationale
le musée d'auschwitz birkenau n'y
échappe pas depuis l'adoption de la
nouvelle loi
son directeur a reçu des centaines de
messages haineux l'accusant de faire
trop de place aux juifs dont un million
pour perrine ici on ne fait pas de
politique ici aux fuites semblent toutes
ces histoires en fait font partie de la
grande histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale la terreur imposée par chaque
année depuis 30 ans des milliers de
jeunes de partout dans le monde les
initie à auschwitz pour la marche des
vivants
la marche qui commémore qui célèbre la
vie des six millions de juifs qui ont
péri dans l'holocauste
cette année la marche a été une rare
occasion pour les présidents de la
pologne et d'israël de se parler et
d'apaiser un peu la crise politique
provoquée par la nouvelle loi polonaise
sur pitch c'est toi et tes rené elle
doit être changée 17 anciens prisonniers
le long du parcours de la marche des dix
ans
cette affiche nous demandons pardon pour
l'antisémitisme polonais signé chrétiens
de pologne en principe pour l'avoir tenu
en public ses auteurs pourrait écoper
d'une peine de prison
deux jours après la marche des vivants
une toute autre pologne marchait
simultanément à deux endroits du pays le
camp national radical et la jeunesse le
tout l'est pologne deux groupes
d'extrême droite parfaitement légaux